mother tells us he was killed by
soldiers during protests
in the capital kampala last november he
was 15 years old
and had gone with her to the family's
shop in the city
when news of opposition leader bobby
wines arrest triggered a riot
he was hit by two bullets as they
hurried home more than 50 other people
also died that day
katya manawaya he fell on the ground and
stopped moving
he did not even call out mum for me to
help him i knew he was dead and right
there
i just collapsed well wishes took us to
hospital
but my son was already gone the un and
human rights organizations have blamed
security forces
for using excessive force while breaking
up protests
several opposition candidates including
bobby wine
and patrick amuryat seen being arrested
by police in this video
are challenging president johary
museveni's bid
for a sixth time in office but they have
been blocked from campaigning
and detained multiple times many of our
people lived including candice have been
incarcerated
diagnosed gone through harsh treatment
while museveni has a free ride in every
part of the country that he's
campaigning
government officials insist that
opposition protests are violent
and the leaders have been defying covet
19 regulations
people are burning ties people are
throwing immortals people are addressing
women people erecting roadblocks and
extracting
money people listen listen
people are bringing trucks trippers
and offloading boulders on the road to
block roads
and you say they are peaceful election
violence is not new to uganda
some people however say the stakes are
higher now because more people want
change
the next few days are crucial security
forces have been deployed heavily
in hot spots like this one where
protests by opposition supporters are
common many people we've talked to are
afraid
that if the presidential result is
contested
then things will just get worse hajjara
nakitu tells us she is closing her shop
and moving out of kampala until she can
be sure her only daughter will be safe
there
and she says she has no intention of
voting
in an election she blames for her son's
death
catherine soy al jazeera kampala